OK Jags, great win.  I am as confused as you are
But I think it has something to do
with being outside the country
So I've agreed to have our next game even further
It's going to be on the moon!
What? Like Warren
But how will we get there?
The moon’s like a whole ‘nother PLANET!
I figured out how to win two Super Bowls with Eli Manning
I think I can figure out how to get a
football team to outer space
Leonard!
As a human science major at LSU,
I've been tasked with designing our spaceship
I present to you
The Bortle Rocket
OK Blake, the controls are based on your
awkward throwing motion
So there's only a 58 percent chance
that this journey ends in a completion
McCown's over there.  Why don't we ask the Jets for a ride
Things are looking up for the Jets baby!
I threw a touchdown!
Bro down!
Relax Blake. This ship is calibrated for garbage time
Alright, giddyup Jags, let's do this
Guys? Hey guys?
Wait, am I the only one on this rocketshIIIIII-
Great job team!
We put Bortles on the moon
Now we can bring in a real QB
A proven veteran
Who's been to the playoffs
I give you
Ryan Nassib